In this video, we are going to talk
about background jobs or background
tasks. If you are a back-end developer,
understanding background jobs is very
important so that you can build scalable
and responsive applications or
responsive backends. So what exactly is
a background task and why should you
really care? So a background task is
basically any piece of code that runs
outside of the request response life
cycle, right? This is our request, this
is our response and this is our client.
This is our server, right? any piece of
code or any logic, any workflow which
runs outside of this whole interaction,
this whole client server interaction or
the request response life cycle that we
call as background job or a background
task. Which means that whatever that you
are doing here outside of the request
response life cycle, this does not need
to happen immediately, right? This is
not a missionritical task that needs to
be responded immediately after calling
it. This is not synchronous and that is
the reason we can offload it to a
separate process and finish however we
have programmed it to finish. Right?
However we have programmed it to respond
to whatever client or to whatever
separate process. Why exactly do we need
them? Right? So let's take an example.
Let's say you have an user and you have
a platform some kind of SAS platform.
The user comes to your platform and they
sign up. They sign up to your platform
which means they type their email, they
type their name, they type their
password etc. and they make a request
and that request is made by your front
end whichever UI is represented to the
user and your front end makes a request
or an API call to your server to your
back end and your server does whatever
processing whatever validation etc it
needs to do for the email for the
password for the length of the password
for the complexity of the password etc
and after that is successful. What it
needs to do? It needs to send an email
to that user to this user. So that if
you have ever signed up to different
platforms, you must have noticed this
workflow that whenever you sign up to
their platform, you give them your
email, you give them a password and they
send a verification email to your
provided email so that they can verify
that whatever email that you have
provided that actually belongs to you
and you're not providing any random
email that you don't actually own,
right? That is one of the ways to verify
that you own the email. What they do,
they send a verification email which
contains either a link which you can
click on and that redirects you to the
front end and it asks you to provide a
new password etc etc or it can also
provide you a code right a sixdigit code
or 8digit code that you need to type
into the front-end interface right some
kind of one-time password so this is how
the workflow
looks like and when you sign up to a new
platform. Now the point to focus here is
the user comes to your platform they
type their email they type their name
the username whatever and they click on
sign up and your front end makes a
request an API call to your back end and
your back end does whatever the initial
processing it needs to do and then it
sends an email to the user. Now this is
the task that we want to focus here the
sending the email to the user and this
is one of the examples of a workflow or
a task that we usually offload to
background processes and the reason
being when you want to send an email to
user what actually happens is you are
subscribed or you are using some
third-party application right? Some
third party platform to send your email,
some email provider, right? It can be a
provider, some modern providers like
resend, bravo. There are a lot of email
providers that we use and how it
actually works is you construct whatever
the content of your email is. Uh let's
say you have an HTML template that you
want to send to the user and you fill
the template with whatever code or
whatever link that you want to send to
actually verify the email and you take
that HTML template and you provide what
is the email address that you want to
send to. This is the email address of
the user
and you provide the subject you provide
which email that you want to send from
etc etc right whatever the default
parameters is for sending an email
through an email provider to an SMTP
provider and you make an API call to a
different service your back end makes an
another API call to the server of
whatever email provider that you're
using recent mail gun etc etc Now that
server processes your email. It checks
whatever it needs to check whether you
own this email, whether you have the
correct API key, etc., etc. And if
everything is successful, it sends the
email. However, that server has
configured to send emails and it sends
the response back to your server that
whether the email sending was successful
or not or whether it was a failure or
not, etc., etc. Now the reason we want
to offload this to a background task
offloading this particular interaction
you your back end calling another back
end or another server for sending the
email is because this server may not be
as responsive as our own server right
because we don't have control over other
servers and for some reason for some
kind of traffic spike or some kind of
service downtime etc. There can be a lot
of reasons. So for some reason let's say
this service is down and assuming we
were not doing this whole email sending
workflow in a background job. We were
doing it synchronously. What happens?
Your server server does all the
processing. It makes the database calls.
It stores the initial data of the user
in the database and it creates a
verification code etc etc and it calls
this API and this API call fails. So
there can be multiple parts here. One is
if you are not properly handling the
error of this API failing and because of
that what happens this API call this
whole the user signing up this API call
this also fails if you don't have proper
error handling for this API right the
email sending it this API and that gives
a very bad user experience if your
signup API fails itself now the second
thing is let's say you have proper error
handling in place and if you do have
that then only this interaction fails
right the signup API itself works
properly but this interaction fails and
even in that case the signup is
successful and in the front end you are
showing that we have sent you a
verification email and you can use that
to verify your account right but Since
this never actually succeeded and you
told the user that we have already sent
the email. So that again gives a very
bad user experience. Now what they have
to do they have to come again to the
platform and they have to if you have
the functionality. they can click on
resend email and again if the recend
email resend email now that is a
different API call and by then if the
service is up then all good you can
resend the email and they can verify the
account and if the service is still down
then again this part of the API is
failed and you show the user that we
have sent you an email again right and
etc etc you can imagine how that
experience goes
So that's how it works in a synchronous
workflow when you do all the processing
in the same process that your API is
working in in the same request response
life cycle. Now imagining let's say
let's go to a different diagram we have
a user they come to your front-end
platform they type their name type their
email and your front end platform makes
that request to your server right now
the server does the all the initial
processing then what it does at last
after doing all the processing etc
generating the verification code
constructing the email instead of
sending the email or instead of calling
the API
of the email provider to send the email
in the same method in the same function
in the same request in the same request
response life cycle. What it does, it
takes all the content, all the
information that we need to send the
email and it packages that into some
format. Let's say a JSON format like it
serializes it into a JSON format. All
the information that we need to send the
email and it injects it into some kind
of Q, right? Some kind of Q. We have a
lot of tasks here or maybe the queue is
empty at this point. does not matter but
it pushes this task into a queue and
what it does after it pushes the task
into the queue the API call does not
happen at that point it just says that
this is a new task this is a new
function call that we need to trigger or
that we need to execute at some point at
somewhere we don't know that yet right
and it pushes that into the cube And
after that it returns and by return we
mean returns some kind of success status
code either 20 0 or 201 depending on
whatever semantics that you're using and
because of this workflow what happens
the user signs up
and your front end makes the API call
and they immediately see that screen
that we have sent a verification email
to your provided email. So you can use
the link in that email to verify your
account and that takes care of creating
the task part. Coming to a different
side of this execution. Let's say here
after we created the task and pushed it
into the queue. Now what happens on this
side of the task Q is there are
consumers or depending on which
framework or which language that you're
using there are consumers or there are
workers etc. What they do they take out
this particular task from this queue and
depending on the configuration and there
can be a lot of different types of
configuration and depending on what kind
of scale that you're executing if you
have different different types of nodes
different nodes for producers different
nodes for consumers but we are talking
in a very high level overview to
understand how the workflow exactly
works what they do they take out this
task from the queue some kind of
consumer. And when I say consumer, what
we mean is a program that runs in a
different process from our main process
from our main backend application.
Right? this different process it picks
up this particular task and since we had
serialized the all the information in
the task into some kind of format let's
say JSON format here it des serializes
into whatever the native language format
is let's say if it's Python it des
serializes into a dictionary if it's
JavaScript it des serializes into an
object if it's go it des serializes into
a strct right you get the idea des
serializ it and it has now a native
format for all that data that it needs
to perform that kind of task. Now there
can be different different configs here.
Let's say you have pushed the email into
the email sending queue, right? There
can be a different queue for sending
notifications, for sending inapp
notifications or for sending push
notifications to mobiles. Right? Now
different types of consumers pick up
different tasks from different cues
right those all can be configurable
depending on what library or what
framework that you're using. Now since
it is a email sending queue our email
consumer or email worker picked up this
task and it was in JSON format it des
serializes serialized into a native
format and now it has all the
information that it needs to perform the
task. Now what happens it has all the
information and beforehand what we do in
that consumer side we configure from
which queue we want to pick up the task
from and we also configure what kind of
data that we are expecting to receive
from the task right and that falls under
the d serialization layer of the
consumer then what happens we also
register a method or a handler which is
the code that actually runs when we
provide it the data that it needs to use
for running, right? Which is basically
the same workflow or the same function
that we're running synchronously when we
did not have a background job, right? B
which basically means here at this point
what we do we take all the information
that we need for sending the email which
is the HTML template the sender email
the receiver email the subject etc and
the user ID the user information for
adding the user first name for adding
the user's email etc etc now it has all
the data it needs to send the email now
what it happens It calls the API for
sending the email from different
different email providers depending on
which email provider that you are using.
It can be recent, it can be mail gun, it
can be bravo. Right now this consumer
this finally calls the API which sends
the user the email. Now usually what
happens this all this processing it
happens between a few seconds or even
milliseconds if there are not a lot of
tasks in the queue. So latency is not a
problem when you are trying to send an
email right because the expiry of let's
say verification emails are usually 15
minutes or 20 minutes and since our
email will be delivered in milliseconds
or max to max under 5 to 10 seconds if
you have a lot of traffic and you have a
lot of tasks in your queue right what
happens this consumer causes pay and
this service sends the email and the
user receives the email and they can now
verify their account. And in a different
scenario, what happens since we assumed
in the previous example that if this
service was down and our email sending
this API call fails, right? this API
call fails. What happens now is since
this API failed, this consumer process,
this consumer function that the handler
that we registered with the consumer,
this also fails, which means our task,
this particular task has failed. At this
point, if we were processing
synchronously, our the request response
life cycle breaks and we return some
kind of code. Since it's an server
error, we return a 500 internal server
error. Now that it's happening in the
background, what happens if a task fails
and depending on what framework that
you're using? If you're using Python,
you have something like celery. If
you're using NodeJS, you have something
like Bullmq. In Go, you have something
like async Q. Right? Depending on what
library or what framework that you're
using for all this background task
processing, background task execution,
when a task fails, it is again injected
into the queue for retrying. And for
retries, we have different different
algorithms. One of the popular algorithm
is exponential back off which basically
means after a task fails, it will try
after let's say 1 minute, it'll retry
that task. If it again fails, it will
try after 2 minutes. It will increase
the time. It will increase the whole
time every time the task fails. And of
course, we have a maximum amount of
retries that we have configured
beforehand. Let's say five times. So
after it fails the second time, we'll
try after 4 minutes. After it fails the
third time, we'll try after 8 minutes.
And usually if you're using an email
provider, a big email provider like
recent or mail gun, the services don't
go down or your APIs don't fail for like
4 minutes, 8 minutes straight. Usually
the downtime will be in seconds or
milliseconds. So for those cases, it
might fail let's say once or max twice,
but the third time it'll most likely
succeed. the service, the external
service will be back up again and your
email sending will be successful and the
user will receive the email. And since
we offloaded this whole email sending
workflow to a background task even if
the external service was down, we were
able to send the email successfully with
all this retrying mechanism etc. And
that is another advantage of using
background task processing because of
this very convenient functionalities
like retrying mechanisms and failure
detection etc etc. So now we have a very
general idea about how background task
processing works and why do we use them?
What are the advantages? One of the
advantage is the faster processing time,
the responsiveness of our backend
application so that we don't block our
actual API call because of some external
service or because of some heavy
processing. And second is we have
retrying mechanisms for tasks which are
prone to failing. Now to summarize
background tasks allow you to offload
time consuming and non-critical
operations and because of that your
backend application your actual backend
API calls they are responsive they
prevent timeouts because of dependency
on external services and it
significantly improves your overall user
experience. Now what are some major
examples or what are some major kind of
tasks that we usually in a typical SAS
applications offload to background. One
which we already saw is sending emails.
Sending emails since it depends on an
external service we offloaded to a
background task which we already
discussed the whole workflow of. The
second is processing images or videos.
So if you have a workflow where the user
uploads an image and what you have to do
is you have to take that image and you
have to resize it or you have to resize
it into different different format so
that the image can be optimized for
delivery depending on the network
conditions of the user or the device of
the user. Since in mobile smartphones we
usually need smaller size images and in
desktop applications in big size 2 XL XL
etc. we need big images for all these
kinds of tasks processing images or
processing videos can be offloaded to
background. Third we have generating
generating reports. So if you are
running some kind of enterprise
application, enterprise SAS application,
let's say take an example of a project
management application. So you have to
send weekly reports or daily reports or
monthly reports depending on your
configuration of the user. represent
reports which are basically PDF files,
emails of all the stats, all the process
task, all the completed task, all the
pending task, all the pendings task in a
sprint etc etc. In a typical project
management application, you have to
construct a email with all the content
directly in the HTML format or in a PDF
format. You have to generate that report
in the PDF format and you have to send
the email daily at midnight at 12:00
weekly on Sunday at 12:00 etc. Right?
For these kinds of tasks also we offload
them to backgrounds using chron jobs.
Right? And if you're using a framework
or a library like salary bulmq they also
have features for scheduled task so that
you can configure a particular date a
particular time and those task will be
executed again and again on those
particular intervals. Those features are
provided by different different
libraries or again sending push
notifications. Push notification
basically means all the notification
that you receive in your smartphone
right on your notification bar from
different apps. If you have apps like
Swiggy, Zumato, you receive these
notifications to order food or your
delivery guy has reached a restaurant
etc etc. Right? These are called push
notifications that your user receive in
the smartphone directly in the
notification panel instead of inside the
app. And usually how it works is you
have a back end. Let's say the Zumato or
Swiggy, they have the back end. Whenever
you install the app in your phone, let's
say you install the Swiggy app in your
phone, your device is registered under
this push notification service. And
usually it is provided by your operating
system. So Google has their own push
notification service and Apple has their
own push notification service etc etc.
Now what happens your back end has to
store this devices some kind of code in
their database and whenever they want to
send a particular notification to a
particular device. They have to make a
service call to Google or Apple
depending on which operating system
their user is using. And these external
services like Google and Apple, they
actually send the notification to you.
Not the back end cannot send the
notification directly to your phone. It
is done by your operating system, right?
Operating system service. The back end
actually stores the code of your device
in the database and it uses that to send
you a notification. So since this
workflow also involves making an API
call making a service call to a
different service external service we
also offload this to a background task.
Now these are some of the major examples
of when do we actually use background
tasks in a typical backend application.
Now let's get a little technical and
understand what exactly is a task Q and
how do they actually work. Now to go by
definition, a task Q is just a system
for managing and distributing background
jobs or tasks. And this is actually the
mechanism, the behind thescenes
technology that enables you to offload
task to reliably hand off the work that
you want to do in the background to a
separate process. Right? This is the
core let's say engine that works behind
the scenes to enable this whole
workflow. Now the core idea is you have
a producer which is your application
code. It can be NodeJS code or Python
code or Golang code right depending on
what language you're using what
framework that you're using your
application code which creates the task
which creates the task and pushes that
into the queue the queue this is the
task Q this is called the producer the
responsibility of the producer the work
of the producer is it will create the
task And that creation process will have
all the information the consumer the
worker will need to process or execute
the task. So the producer will take all
that information and it will serialize
it into a JSON format or any other kind
of serializable any other kind of
serializable format that your framework
or the your library uses. It serializes
that data it creates the task and it
pushes that into the cube. That is all
the work of a producer. Then on the
other side you have the consumer. You
have the consumer which basically runs
in a different process. It can be in the
same backend application code or it can
be a separate codebase also right? It
runs in a different process and what it
does it picks out those tasks and it
actually runs them. it executes those
tasks depending on what is the execution
code or what is the handler that you
have registered for a particular task.
This is how the whole interaction works
on a very high level. So this is like
imagine a to-do list for your back end.
Your application code adds the tasks
into the to-do list and the workers or
the consumers they pick them off one by
one and they execute them. Right? a
to-do list for your backend application.
So technically speaking on a high level
the producer this part it creates a task
and the task might contain information
like the user ID or the user profile
information like the name of the user
the email of the user that we'll need
for processing that task. it'll have all
the information and if it is an image
processing task it will have the image
or if it is a report sending task it
will have all the data that it needs to
send the report etc etc right and the
producer this process of pushing the
task into the queue it is called nqing
right if you are familiar with data
structures and algorithms the process of
pushing a new item into the queue it is
called and queuing the task which means
adding a new item to the task. Now this
part this is called a broker. The queue
is also called a broker. Now this is
responsible for storing these tasks
until a worker is ready to process them
which happens on the this side other
side. So this is like a temporary
holding area until consumers or workers
can pick up these tasks and start
processing. And this part the consumer
or the worker this runs in a separate
process or a separate thread. The
technicalities can be different
depending on what language what
framework and what library that you're
using but the core fundamentals remain
the same. This consumer, it runs in a
separate process. And the way it picks
these tasks is it constantly monitors
the queue for new items, for new items
being pushed into the queue. And when it
sees a new task, when it finds a new
task, it dqes it. The process of taking
out an item from a queue, it's called
DQing. And it dqes that task and it
starts executing it. So that is the
highlevel technical overview of how a
task Q actually works. Now going a
little more deep. When a task is NQed, a
task this is called NQ and is called DQ.
This is also called the broker. Right?
So when a task is NQed, it is
serializable. It is serialized into a
JSON format. Right? This is an important
part of ENQing a task. Now this
underlying system this Q so far we've
been talking in a very abstract way like
task Q etc. Usually these are
technologies. So speaking of examples,
this can be technologies like Rabbit MQ
or Radius,
PubSub, right? Radius has a very useful
module called publisher and subscriber
module which are usually used for
implementing task use, right? Or it can
be SGS which is a managed queuing
service from AWS. Right? If you are
considering scaling your task management
or task processing system to different
nodes which are spread across the whole
world then Amazon SQS is a good solution
which is managed service provided by AWS
which are deployed in multiple regions
so that you have a very scalable and a
very responsible task processing system
in place. So this queue this broker
which actually stores the task right
this is usually managed by an underlying
technology like rabbit MQ or radius
pubsub etc. So what happens is when the
worker or when the consumer it completes
the task it sends an acknowledgement an
acknowledgement back to the queue. This
tells a Q that the task was successfully
processed and it can be removed. But if
it does not send an acknowledgement, the
Q can decide depending on different
parameters that whether the task was
unresponsive in that case it will try a
different retrying mechanism. If the
task failed in that case it will try a
different retrying mechanism. Right? All
these frameworks like celery, bulmq,
asyncq, all these very popular
frameworks for task processing. They
have all the features in place to manage
all these different kinds of edge cases.
In this whole interaction, we also have
a concept called visibility timeout
which basically means that this is the
period this whole workflow. This
visibility timeout is the period when a
task is considered in progress, right?
by a consumer or by a worker. And if the
worker or the consumer it does not
acknowledge the task, it does not send
the acknowledgement signal back to the
queue within that timeout, right?
Whatever timeout we have configured
depending on a configuration. If it does
not the worker, the consumer does not
send an acknowledgement signal within
the timeout probably because it crashed
or probably because the external service
hung up. It can be a lot of reasons.
What the Q will do is the Q will make
the task. It will take the task and it
will make it available to other
consumers or other workers so that the
task does not get lost in the whole
interaction. And the reason being since
the way our task processing systems work
is we the publisher pushes a task into
the queue and consumers take out task
from the queue. they process it and the
cues remove the task from the queue.
Right? And since the consumer already
took out a particular task from the
queue and it was not able to acknowledge
the success or the failure of the task.
We don't want the task to get lost in
the whole interaction. That's why we
have this feature called visibility
timeout. uh because of that the Q
ensures that our task don't get lost and
when a consumer or when a worker is not
able to send a particular
acknowledgement signal it will make that
particular task available to other
consumers or other workers so that they
can start processing. So someone has to
send an acknowledgement signal back to
the queue to mark a particular task
either as success or failure. Now let's
talk about different kinds of tasks that
we usually encounter in a backend
application. So the first example is
pretty simple that we have already seen
one of task which means uh something
happens in your in your request request
response life cycle and you want to
perform a single task which is like a
trigger depending on a particular
scenario we want to execute a particular
function in background. So sending an
email is a good example of one of task.
A user registered. You want to send them
a verification email. The verification
was successful. You want to send them an
welcome email. And someone wants to
reset their password. You want to send
them an email so that using that link
they can reset their password. Let's say
it's a social media application and
someone texted you and you want to send
them send the user a notification. So
that's again a one-off task, right? So
these are examples of one-off task which
you will encounter more frequently as
compared to other task. But other tasks
also have their place. Then we have
recurring tasks. Recurring tasks are
basically tasks which have to be
executed periodically in specific
intervals. And examples of that can be
sending a particular report, sending
daily reports or sending monthly reports
or sending annual reports to your users
for whatever the stats in that quarter,
in that year or in that month or in that
day etc. Recurring task also can contain
cleanup or maintenance jobs. So let's
say you have an authentication system in
place and for authenticating users you
use stateful technologies and for
implementing stateful authentication you
have to store all the sessions of the
user in your database in the sessions
table and what happens as the user logs
in logs out logs in logs out for a long
time they have a lot of abandoned or a
lot of orphan sessions which are not
really active but they're still in your
database since you never actually
deleted them. So you have a task or a
recurring task which executes let's say
in every 3 months or in every 2 months
or in every month end of the month or
starting of the month what it does it
goes through all the orphan sessions all
the sessions which are not active and
it's been a long
time. So you actually go and delete them
from your database. so that you have
some free storage. The orphan sessions
are not taking unused space in your
database. So those are some examples of
recurring tasks. Then we also have chain
tasks. Chain task basically have parent
child relationship between different
different kinds of task. So let's say
you have an LMS platform. LMS means
learning management system. So some of
the popular LMS platforms are let's say
Udemy etc. Right now let's imagine you
have an LMS platform of your own and
what happens the user the instructor
whoever is creating courses in that
platform they can come into the platform
and they can create a new course and for
creating a new course what do they have
to do? What they have to do is they have
to upload videos. they have to upload
videos into the platform. Right? Now a
typical workflow of uploading videos
into an LMS platform might look like the
user comes they click on upload video
and they select the video that they want
to upload and they click enter and the
video starts uploading and the
technically how it works is the front
end takes that video and it immediately
the back end immediately sends an
acknowledgement so that the request is
not blocked but the uploading process is
in progress. address right it can be
uploaded to S3 using a pre-signed URL
right the implementation can be
different after the video is uploaded it
number of tasks can be triggered the
first task can be the video has to be
taken and it has to be processed so that
the video is available in different
different resolutions depending on the
network condition of the user or the
device of the user etc right the video
has to be encoded to different formats
to cater to a wide range of network
conditions and a wide range of devices.
So that is your first task and after
that video is processed and second task
has to be triggered which depends on the
first task which is the video has to be
encoded first. Now the second task is
the thumbnails for that video has to be
generated right after the video is
encoded to a particular format so that
that video can be served efficiently
from different different CDNs uh content
delivery networks or whatever platforms
that you're using. After the video is
encoded then we have to trigger a
different task so that the thumbnails
for that video has to be generated.
After the thumbnail has been generated,
now we have to trigger another task
which is those thumbnail images they
have to be processed so that we have
different different resolutions of the
same thumbnail images for different
network conditions and for different
devices. Now this thumbnail image
processing task depends on thumbnail
generation task. But at the same time
after the video is encoded at the same
time we started the thumbnail generation
task we can parallelly start another
task which is transcription generation
right the audio transcription generation
to show to the user when the video is
playing the basically the subtitles. Now
this task the audio transcription
generation and this task the thumbnail
generation since they are not dependent
on each other they can be started
parallelly but they both depend on the
task that the video has to be encoded
first. So this kind of interaction this
kind of task chaining this is what we
mean when we say chain task or tasks
which have a parent child relationship
right or some kind of hierarchy. A
particular task can only be triggered
once the parent task is triggered and
successfully completed first. Right?
Those are examples of chain task. Then
we have batch tasks. So one example of
batch task from a real world example is
let's say you have a SAS and you have a
button where the user can click on
delete account right a lot of SAS
platforms offer this feature where you
can delete your account now what happens
when the user actually deletes that
account you don't actually the front end
cannot just make an API call and the
back end cannot just go through all the
data of the user in in the database and
they cannot just delete it in the same
request, right? Since if it's a big
platform, the user might have a lot of
data, right? And they might have data in
a database which are spread across
different different shards or different
different regions etc. Right? There can
be a lot of different types of
conditions and lot of different types of
data of a user that we have in the
platform and all of those cannot be
deleted in a single request response
life cycle. Even if it can be deleted,
it might take let's say more than 40 or
50 seconds or let's say worst case more
than a minute, right? And we cannot
stall or we cannot block an API call for
that long. And for that reason what
happens whenever the delete account API
call is made what we do we immediately
respond back with a successful uh
response like 200 and we say that your
account deletion task is in progress and
the user is logged out from the platform
and they are given some kind of grace
period that you have 3 days or you have
7 days to log back into the account and
cancel the deletion process or the
account will be permanently deleted
after the end of 3 days. That can be one
use case or the second use case is let's
say you don't have a grace period.
You're not a big platform like AWS. In
that case, what you do the moment the
delete account API call is made the
front end immediately receives the
successful response that the back end
sends back and it logs the user out. And
for that user the account is deleted
permanently from our platform. But what
exactly happens is the back end takes
whenever the back end receives the
delete account API call. What it does?
It creates a task which is delete
account and it pushes that task into the
queue and it immediately responds back a
successful response like 200 and the
front end does it job. And for the back
end what happens the consumer which is
responsible for actually performing the
task of deleting an account it picks
that task from the queue and it starts
the deletion process which might be
going through all the resources of the
user. Let's say if it's a project
management application going through all
the projects where the user is the
owner. So removing all the entities of
the user from that project and then
deleting the profile of the user,
deleting the assets of the user like
logos, cover images and then at last
actually deleting the user account,
right? Then sending some kind of email
to the user that your account has been
deleted etc etc. So all of those things
happen in background which means our API
call is not blocked and that is an
example of batch tasks right because it
involves calling a lot of task from a
single task. So delete account task
itself can call a lot of tasks for
deleting the entities of the user
deleting the assets of the user right
those can be batch task triggering a lot
of task from a single task. Another
example of a batch task can be let's say
at 12:00 or midnight or at the end of
the week you have to send report to a
particular user. Now since you are a big
platform you have a lot of users. So at
the same time you trigger a lot of tasks
let's say thousands of tasks which all
do the same thing generating a report
and sending to the user but since it
happens for a lot of user that also we
can consider as a batch tasks right
sending thousands of reports to
thousands of users at a particular
interval right those are some of the
different types of background tasks that
we usually deal with now these are some
of the design considerations s that you
have to account for when working with
task use or working with background task
especially when we are talking about
scale when you're talking about
thousands of users when it's a big
platform you're managing the back end of
a big platform and it's concerned about
the background task processing first
thing is it potency this basically means
that whatever task that you're creating
that you are executing you have to
design them in a way that they can be
safely executed multiple times without
causing any side effects. Right? In case
of let's say failure of the task. Let's
say for example in our delete account
task you have in your in our delete
account task in a typical delete account
task what you do is we go through all
the resources all the entities of the
user uh in the database and we start
removing them or we start setting them
null etc etc depending on our
requirements. Now the what we mean by
Adamency in that context is you have to
do all of them in a particular
transaction right a particular
transaction so that what happens let's
say you start deleting stuff from the
database and down the road something
fails right it can be something related
to database or it can be an external
service call right calling an API
getting some kind of data of the user
etc right it can be anything at this
point. If something fails here, if you
are executing all of this in a single
transaction, what you can do it? You can
do a custom roll back, right? A manual
roll back. So what happens since this
task has failed when the next time the
the task Q retries this task, we start
from scratch, right? We start from 0%
completion. And this is what we mean by
item potent. You have to design your
tasks in a way that they don't cause any
side effects in case something fails
down the line and you have to retry that
task from scratch. Same way error
handling you have to make sure that you
have very robust and very extensive
error handling in place especially in
tasks management systems because
everything is happening in a different
process right so you have to make sure
you don't miss anything you don't miss
any bottlenecks you don't miss any edge
cases etc etc right so you have to
implement robust error handling to catch
and to log errors also to redry failed
tasks. Right? So this is very important
in a task management system. Then you
have to set up proper monitoring. And
what we mean by monitoring is you have
to track the status of how many tasks
that you currently have in your queue.
What are the number of successful tasks?
What are the number of failed tasks? And
what is the major reason of failed task?
It is. Is it some kind of external
service or is it some kind of internal
error etc etc right at any point you
have to have the complete view of what
is the status of your whole task
management system so you can use
technology like Prometheus right using
graphana and tools like that so every
time a new task is created you can in
insert a new metrics we'll cover things
like metrics instrumentation elastic elk
stag etc etc all these things related to
logs traces monitoring in a different
video but we use this technique called
metrics where every time something
happens some kind of trigger we create a
new metrics and we insert it into some
kind of stack in this case we have
graphana to monitor what are the
different metrics currently that our
back back end application have and we
have ways to persist those metrics in
disk different replication techniques
etc etc. Right? So for your task
processing system you have to have all
these monitoring techniques in place so
that at all times you can monitor what
is the status of your system. Same way
you have to design your system in a way
that it scales so that down the lane if
you require more processing power right
let's say you your user base spiked and
you have to cater to more users now
double the amount of users now so what
you have to do is you have to add more
number of consumers right so you have to
design it in a way that down the lane
you can scale your consumers
horizontally right you can add more
nodes to your consumer customer so that
the processing remains as responsive as
ever. Same way if you require ordering
you have to make sure that whatever
library, whatever framework, whatever
task you that you are using, they
support ordered delivery. Right? Tasks
have to be executed in a particular
order. You have to make sure that your
particular library or framework supports
that. Same way we also have rate
limiting. So if your task interact with
external services, you have to implement
proper rate limiting to prevent
overloading those services, right?
Because those services also charge you
for number of API calls and they also
have their own API rate limiting or
technique etc etc right so you have to
take this also into
consideration while designing your
tasks. So these are some of the design
considerations you have to keep in mind
when you're working with a task
management or background task management
system. Now talking about some of the
best practices that I can recommend from
my own experience of dealing with these
task background task management systems
is the first thing is keep your task
small and focused which basically means
a single task should only be concerned
about a single processing unit. Right?
You should not do a lot of things in a
single task. So you have to design your
task in a way that you have to divide
the responsibilities between different
tasks so that if one task fails it does
not affect other tasks. If the one task
one processing is dependent on a
different task then what you can do is
you can go for chain task right. You can
have a parent child relationship so that
a task can be scaled in that way so that
even if the child fails the parent does
not fail right the child failing is a
different task. So the retrying
mechanism can handle that with
exponential backoff or whatever. But if
you do a lot of things in a single task,
what happens is even if the topmost
processing is successful but somewhere
down the lane something fails then the
whole thing has to be repeated all over
again right and if you're trying to add
a lot of stuff into a single task then
that wastes a lot of processing power of
your CPU of your consumer of your server
right so if you keep your task focused
and small it's easier to scale it's
easier to avoid bugs and it's easier to
monitor them, right? And it's also
easier for your queue to implement
different mechanisms like retries, etc.
Same way, always try to avoid longunning
tasks. If you have a task that takes a
long time to complete, break it down to
smaller and more manageable chunks.
Right? As I said, this is something
similar to the above point. If you have
a task which is doing a lot of stuff
then of course it's going to take a lot
of time which is a signal to you that
it's about time that you divide this
particular task into different task
either different tasks which are
concurrently processed or different
tasks which have a parent child
relationship depending on your
requirements. Same way using proper
error handling and logging. This is as I
said one of the most important things
when we are dealing with background task
processing. You have to have proper
error handling in place so that you give
a chance to your queue for retrying and
you have all the information you need to
debug whatever happened in your task
which made it fail or whether it is an
external service whether it is an
internal error or everything. So you
need all these error handling techniques
or logging techniques so that it's
easier for you to debug things. It's
easier for you to monitor things to find
out where the problem is and it's also
easier for the queue to perform various
retrying mechanisms. And at last you
have to constantly monitor Q length and
worker health which basically means you
have to have proper alerting systems in
place so that if the Q length exceeds a
particular limit you have to come up
with different techniques to make it
more scalable or if some of the workers
are going down for some reason you have
to debug them what exactly is the error
that is causing them to go down etc etc.
You have to have proper alerting
mechanism so that at all times you are
aware that your system your whole task
background task management systems is
running smoothly. Now to recap,
background tasks are essential for
building scalable for building reliable
and responsive backend applications and
they allow you to offload time consuming
and non-critical operations to improve
the user experience and to prevent
timeouts and to enable redrawing
mechanisms for dependency on external
services and for heavy processing tasks
That's pretty much all about task use
that you need to know as a back end
engineer.